after the media spend four years warning
of incipient dictatorship president
biden decides to govern by executive
fiat
confusion still reigns on biden's
coveted policy and 45 senate republicans
vote
essentially to dismiss impeachment i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let big tech track what you do
anonymize your web browsing at
expressvpn.com
ben we're gonna get to everything in the
news in just one moment first you should
be
attempting to save money this year i
mean you should every year but now would
be a really good time to save money
considering
the state of the economy so take a look
at your bill and what you will see is
that you're spending an awful lot of
money on your cell phone like a lot of
money on your cell coverage you don't
need to instead
why not switch over to pure talk usa
from a t verizon
or t-mobile when you do you could save
over 800 a year
that's real money every single month
right back in your pocket you don't have
to sacrifice coverage pure talk is on
the same network as one of the big
carriers but they charge you half
that's right no gimmicks no fluff added
to the bills that is why pure talk is
the top rated wireless company by
consumer affairs
and how about this offer right now you
can get unlimited talk text and six gigs
of data for just 30 bucks a month
if you go over on data usage they're not
going to charge you for it grab your
mobile phone
dial dialpound250 say ben shapiro when
you do
you save 50 off your first month why
would you be spending a lot more money
for cell phone coverage that is like
exactly the same as the cell phone
coverage you could get from pure talk
usa for maybe half the cost
dial pound two five zero say keyword ben
shapiro pure talk usa
simply smarter wireless again now pound
250 say ben shapiro when you do you save
off your first month and then hundreds
down the road alrighty so
joe biden he is supposed to be moderate
right i mean this is what we've been
told he is a moderate he is
normal and moderate and moderate and
normal and here's the thing about joe
biden
he constantly says things about the
constitution that are kind of true
and then he just proceeds to ignore them
so i want to flash you back to the
middle of the campaign and joe biden is
being
interviewed by george stephanopoulos
democratic operative and
abc news anchor and george
stephanopoulos is asking him
why exactly he can't just do things why
don't you just do things you know if you
become president why don't you just do
things
and joe biden says you know you're going
to have to use the legislature because
there's this thing called the
legislature it's in the constitution
and the president cannot just govern by
executive fiat if he does
this makes him a dictator okay now this
is not me saying this it happens to be
true
it's not me saying this it is joe biden
saying this here is joe biden
circa just a couple of months ago
talking about how presidents are not
supposed to govern by executive fiat
the one thing i i have this strange
notion
we are a democracy some of my republican
friends and some of my democratic
friends even occasionally say
well if you can't get the votes by
executive order you're going to do
something
things you can't do by executive order
unless you're a dictator
we're democracy we need consensus oh we
need consensus do we
and and also you can't just do things by
executive order is it also that's
that'd be a dictatorship if there was
just one guy who could you know just use
executive orders
and and put his whims into law that way
wouldn't that be
kind of dictatorial it seems okay now
flashback to the present
joe biden is now the president of the
united states according to hank berry
and daly wire through monday january
25th the sixth day of his tenure in
office
joe biden had issued 28 executive orders
dwarfing the initial number of executive
orders issued by former presidents in
the initial days of their tenure
former president trump signed four
executive orders in the first week of
his tenure with a total of 220 executive
orders signed in his total time as
president former president barack obama
signed five in the first week 276
overall
former president george w bush signed
zero in his first week
former president bill clinton signed one
in his first week
presidential biden has signed 28 in the
first
six days apparently he signed a few more
yesterday that means he is up to 33
he is up to 33 executive orders and
these executive orders
are policy making instruments right
these actually have a real impact on
policy now
what were executive orders originally
meant to do not this
generally an executive order and i've
been very much anti-executive orders
since as long as i can remember because
this is not how the constitution was
supposed to operate
in fact if you look in the constitution
you'll notice there is
no verbiage with regard to executive
orders there is no phrase executive
orders
in fact there's no phrase presidential
proclamations a lot of the stuff that
presidents use these days is not
actually in the constitution
so what exactly are executive orders
well they've been used since the
beginning of the republic essentially
to allow the executive branch to
effectuate the will of the legislature
the idea was
the legislature tells the executive
branch to do something and now the
executive branch has to do it
but the legislature has not been
specific enough in how they want the
executive branch to do it and so now the
executive branch has to effectuate that
right it's it's as though my wife tells
me that she wants me to clean the dishes
i'm gonna fill in all the blanks okay i
need to use a sponge i need to use the
soap right that would be the executive
order my wife's mandate to clean the
dishes is the legislature and i am the
executive who is now in charge of
cleaning the dishes there are a bunch of
things i have to do in order to make
that happen
okay that is how the delegation is
supposed to work the legislature
delegates power to the executive and the
executive uses the power that has been
delegated
unfortunately that is not what has
happened and
it's not rare for presidents to overrun
their executive authority the difference
is that now nobody seems to care
it really is quite incredible
essentially what we have in this country
is a is a congress
that sometimes passes giant omnibus
packages that spend a lot of money
and delegates tremendous authority to
the executive branch which is staffed by
two million people
hundreds of thousands in various under
the auspices of various regulatory
agencies
they turn out tens of thousands of pages
of regulations that are highly specific
and govern your everyday life more of
what happens your in your everyday life
is governed by the workings of the
regulatory agencies inside the executive
branch than is governed
by congress itself and congress is just
there to pass defense bills
and sometimes cut your taxes or raise
your taxes or to
pass these omnibus spending packages
that's pretty much it
that's all they do okay they are a
vestigial organ of government
they exist almost the way that the
parliament used to exist in great
britain with regard to the king
that they were just there to basically
fund whatever the king wanted to do
right the king would go to parliament
and if he didn't get what he wanted from
parliament then he would then he would
dissolve parliament then he'd call a new
parliament and then parliament would
give him the money that he wanted
that's essentially what we do now the
only difference is that we elect our
dictator every four years
every four years we get to decide who is
going to issue the executive orders
and limitations on executive orders have
been
really falling apart for 100 years
essentially
fdr issued tons and tons of executive
orders that really outstrip the power
of the office the supreme court case
that typically is used
to discuss exactly what executive orders
are allowed to do
is a case that is called youngstown
youngstown
sheet and tube company versus sawyer
okay this is a case that cropped up
during the truman administration
basically we're in the middle of the
korean war and there was a labor union
at a steel mill and the labor union
decided to strike at the steel mill
and truman because we were in the middle
of a war and we needed steel
instead of trying to use the
taft-hartley act to break the union
right instead of using the taft-hartley
actually joined the strike for 60 days
instead truman decided essentially to
steal the seize the steel mill
he said he said i have the executive
authority to just take away private
property
for war production well the supreme
court said well actually you can't do
that by executive order that is not
something you can do
by executive fiat there's a justice
named
robert jackson and justice jackson then
proceeded to write
a a concurrence and he spelled out
exactly what executive orders are for
and here is what he said
he said presidential powers are not
fixed but fluctuates depending upon
their disjunction or conjunction
with those of congress and then he
created what he called an oversimplified
grouping of practical situations in
which a president
may doubt or others may challenge his
powers so one
when the president acts pursuant to an
express or implied authorization of
congress his authority is at its maximum
for it includes all that he possesses in
his own right plus all the congress can
delegate
right that is what i'm talking about is
sort of the original origin of an
executive order
congress says i want you to do x the
president then has to do a bunch of
things in order to effectuate x right
that's a normal executive order then
there's category two
and here is where presidents have begun
to expand their power and they've never
stopped expanding their power
two when the president acts in the
absence of either a congressional grant
or denial of authority he can rely only
upon his
own independent powers but there is a
zone of twilight in which he and
congress may have concurrent authority
or in which
distribution is uncertain therefore
congressional inertia indifference or
quiescence
may sometimes at least as a practical
matter enable if not invite
measures on independent presidential
responsibility in this area any actual
test of power is likely to depend on the
imperatives of events
so basically what you've seen is
presidents have to president declare
that congress has not acted in this area
nor will they act we have gridlock
therefore i'm going to act
in the absence of congress and that is
what you have seen from dubai now the
part of that
that's hilarious is that joe biden
currently controls congress the
democrats control congress
democrats control the senate so he
doesn't need to do that
it's just he doesn't like the fact that
there is a check and balance in congress
he doesn't like the fact that the senate
is not controlled by 60 democratic
senators or 55 democratic senators it is
controlled instead by 50
democratic senators with kamala harris
as the tiebreaker from the vice
presidential seat
and he's got at least two democrats who
are not willing to break the filibuster
so instead he's just
going to do things and the things that
he's going to do are quite dictatorial
in nature
they're far-reaching they have
significant impact
so for example joe biden announced
yesterday he's going to be imposing
government diversity and sensitivity
training this sounds
like something that is not a big deal
right because you said yourself okay
well you know
people should be more sensitive what's
the problem with with sensitivity
training and diversity
like we like diversity diversity is good
what's the problem with diversity okay
what diversity and sensitivity training
generally mean in the context of
corporate and federal
oversight and uh and and training
generally what those mean
are these pathetic struggle sessions in
which you are called before
some sort of human resources quote
unquote expert
and you are explained how if you say
something completely inoffensive it is
actually racist
you are told that white supremacy
dictates
the way that all of america's
institutions work and if you don't
acknowledge your own white
supremacy then this is just because you
are in fact a white supremacist
and this is how a lot of these diversity
training regimens work now trump
banned this in the last months of his
administration he wrote an executive
order
and this governs inside the federal
branch right this is inside the
executive branch so the president
actually does have some power here
because he gets to make the rules for
the people who work for him
and trump said i'm not going to have
federal employees taught a bunch of
claptrap
about how america's institutions are
inherently white supremacist and how if
you believe
in a colorblind meritocracy this means
you're a racist
joe biden comes in and the first thing
he does is he says you know what we're
going to go back to training people
that america is inherently unfair and
cruel and the only way to fix america is
radical change to its institutions
here's joe biden saying this yesterday
in the weeks ahead i'll be reaffirming
the federal government's commitment to
diversity equity and
inclusion and accessibility building on
the work we started
in the obama biden administration that's
why
i'm rescinded the previous
administration's harmful ban on
diversity and sensitivity training
and abolished the offensive counter
factual 1776 commission
unity and healing must begin with
understanding and truth
not ignorance and lies okay so him first
of all calling the 1776 commission
ignorance and lies is insane the 1776
commission
just teaches a traditional version of
american history where america is
generally the good guy
it does not whitewash america's history
of racial discrimination
it does not whitewash the history of
american slavery it does not whitewash
america's history of the treatment of
native americans
okay that is not what it is designed to
do the the basic notion here
that joe biden is pushing is that we
have to inculcate
throughout our federal workforce and
presumably throughout our educational
system
the idea that america is inherently bad
and requires systematic and fundamental
change on every single level
that's a pretty big statement does that
sound moderate to you or does that sound
rather radical to you
and does it sound and he says he is
going to use every area of the federal
government to cram this down
every area of the federal government is
going to inculcate these values
i mean that sounds a lot like using
executive fiat in order to radically
change the nature of the country
okay biden went on along these lines he
said george floyd's death was a knee on
the neck of justice now
the specifics of the george floyd case
are still in dispute there is an ongoing
judicial case about this
there is no evidence that has been
presented thus far suggesting that it
was a racialized killing
okay really i know that this has become
the meme of the day
but the reality is no evidence has been
presented that the killing of george
floyd was racially based
i mean like like not any and the the
best that you can say about the case
is that it was an act of police
brutality okay the you there is no
evidence that derek calvin who's the
officer in that case murdered george
floyd because george floyd was a black
man
in fact there's pretty good evidence to
suggest that derek shalvin
is going to have a fairly solid defense
case george fly was
george floyd was high as a kite on
fentanyl his autopsy showed that he had
enough fentanyl in him to kill a horse
he was probably suffering from excited
delirium the full tape of the situation
shows that george floyd again the police
were called
by a shop owner to the situation because
george floyd had just passed a
counterfeit bill
they show up george floyd resists
arrests for a long time
he begs them not to put him in the car
they they treat him actually pretty well
they say they're going to roll down the
window for him he then attempts to climb
out of the car he begs to be put on the
ground he is put on the ground
and there he suffers a heart attack it's
pretty clear
and ends up dying later that has excited
delirium okay and the minneapolis police
department use of force actually allows
the kind of restraint
that derek schalvin was using so chalvin
is actually going to have a fairly solid
defense case even though the tape is
extremely ugly
and even if you believe that the system
has to be changed in sort of the
way that that force is used okay but the
the point that biden is making is far
broader than that he's not just arguing
that this was an act of police brutality
which
is possible and arguable he's arguing
not only that it is an act of racism
which again no evidence has been
provided to suggest that
he is arguing that it is indicative of
all of american law enforcement that all
of american society
rose up because of the george floyd case
because it was indicative
of how black americans are treated in
this country that's crazy
it is evidence-free and it is being
crammed down from the top of the
american government
if joe biden had campaigned on the
notion that he was going to completely
remake american government
on the basis of critical race theory
equity garbage he would have had a
harder time in that election cycle he
was considered the moderate
on a lot of this stuff inside the
democratic party okay he is not moderate
there's nothing about him that is
moderate on these particular issues
and as we will see this is going to have
some very very real ramifications
yeah well the the basic idea that all of
america's institutions are rife with
racism because george floyd died
while under the knee of derek calvin is
not just a stretch it is a stretch
based on a stretch hey but again the
goal here is is more than anything
transformational change
and whatever tool is available to
leverage transformational change inside
the american government
that is what democrats and joe biden are
about to use and they're about to use
all executive power
in order to accomplish that okay so here
is
here is joe biden talking about george
floyd
what many americans didn't see or had
simply refused to see
couldn't be ignored any longer those uh
eight minutes and 46 seconds that took
george floyd's life opened the eyes of
millions of americans and millions of
people around all over the world
it was the knee on the neck of justice
and it wouldn't be forgotten it stirred
the conscious
and of tens of millions of americans and
in my view it marked a turning point
in this country's attitude toward racial
justice okay just a quick note there are
37 million
black americans living in the united
states as of 2020 according to the
washington post database
they have they've calculated a grand
total they've documented a ground total
of 15
black men shot in america by the police
who are unarmed that is a grand total
in 2020. okay the year before it was 14.
okay so this idea that black people are
being hunted down willy-nilly by the
cops
and that american society is viciously
racist despite the fact that it is
literally illegal to discriminate
in both private and public industries
it's a pretty amazing claim
and yet that is going to be the basis
for an enormous amount of executive
policy because that's how policy gets
done these days
from the top without legislative
approval or legislative input we're
going to get to more of this in just one
second first
let us talk about an institution that
has too much power over your life these
days that would be big tech
big tech companies they have a ton of
power in our country today as private
entities they can operate pretty much
as they feel free to do protect your
personal data from them with the vpn i
trust for my own online protection
express
vpn when i use expressvpn my connection
gets rerouted through their secure
encrypted servers so these companies
can't see my ip address at all
my internet activity becomes anonymized
and my network data is encrypted i
recommend expressvpn to anyone who uses
the internet so
pretty much everyone the best part is
you don't need to be tech savvy at all
to use expressvpn
just download the app on your phone or
computer tap one button you are now
protected
protect your internet activity with the
vpn i use every single day and the fact
of the matter is
you don't you shouldn't trust big tech
to keep control of your information not
only
have they had hacks that have really
harmed people's personal information in
the past
i'll say do you trust the big tech bros
to actually control your information and
not use it against you
i don't visit expressvpn.com to get
three extra months free on a one-year
package that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s vpn.com to
get three extra months for free
expressvpn.com ben okay so
then joe biden calls forth susan rice it
is absolutely astonishing that susan
rice continues to have a career in
public service
she blatantly lied to the american
public lied to the american public
now a couple days ago i was talking
about press secretaries and i say that
their job is
is very often to spin on behalf of their
administrations and this means that the
ones
who are asked to spin on behalf of
people who lie routinely and are blind
right that would be like a lot of
members of the obama administration and
i said that there are people who i think
didn't lie in their job people like dana
parino or tony snow
susan rice lied in her job all the damn
time susan rice
went on national television she
suggested that the benghazi attacks
were a mere uprising the the idea was of
course that it was it was created by a
youtube video as opposed to the complete
malfeasance of the obama era government
susan rice is a radical on a wide
variety of issues she's radical on
foreign policy
she's radical on domestic policy somehow
she ended up as the domestic policy
council director despite the fact that
she was a foreign policy advisor
under barack obama so apparently she's
amazing at everything susan rice she is
so good at everything that now she's
going to run
domestic policy oh goody
so susan rice gets up there by the way
the same
woman who was involved in the unmasking
of michael flynn
and then wrote a little memo to file you
remember this she wrote a little memo to
file we did everything by the book like
the day before she left office
and everybody's like well she wrote a
memo to file that means they did do
everything by the book
she wasn't asked a single question about
any of this stuff at her press
conference yesterday
she said every single agency in american
government is going to be focused on
equity
now people don't understand what the
word equity means when democrats use it
because it sounds so much like equality
equality is not the same thing
as equity equity is a catch-all term
meaning fairness
but the question is how do you determine
what is fair
the left and right have very different
definitions of fairness okay
aristotle and plato defined justice as
people getting essentially what they
deserve that is what justice is
okay but that is not what democrats mean
by justice or fairness what democrats
mean by justice or fairness is you don't
get what you deserve
you get the same thing as the guy next
to you no matter what he deserves and no
matter what you deserve
and not only that it's not just that you
personally get the same thing as the
person next to you it's that we ought to
gauge
by group outcome whether fairness has
been achieved
so if black americans have a lower net
income than white americans
or presumably if white americans have a
lower income than asian americans they
never say that part because that part's
awkward
then group equity has not been achieved
now that last example the fact that
asian american households make more
money than white american households
you're never going to hear democrats
talk about that because because of
course they actually are not in favor
even
of equity in terms of fairness of
outcome they're not even
like they don't even care about that
what they are really about is polarizing
people by racial groups that they can
use them
as a coalition of the quote unquote
oppressed against the supposed white
majority
that is that is oppressing them despite
the fact by the way that white voters
split pretty heavily between democrats
and republicans in ways that
many other domestic racial groups do not
in any case here is susan rice saying
that every agency of the federal
government
is going to be focused on equity which
again means
using the power of the federal
government in order to cram down
equal outcome not protection of
individual rights
on day one the president signed an
executive order
directing an unprecedented whole of
government initiative
to embed racial equity across federal
policies programs
and institutions that starts with a
review of policies and institutions
to redress systemic racism where it
exists
and to advance equity where we aren't
doing enough
every agency will place equity at the
core
of their public engagement okay this is
a terrible idea you know why that's a
terrible idea because let's take a quick
example
and one that happens to be
extraordinarily relevant right now the
example of vaccinations
if you place risk assessment at the top
of your list not equity
that means a lot of old people are going
to get the vaccine because old people
need the vaccine
and people who are five do not if
however you are going to place equity at
the top of your list
this means you're going to give
essential workers who are 20 and black
the vaccine before you give
people who are 65 that vaccine which not
only makes no sense it ends with more
absolute numbers of dead black people
because there are lots of black people
who are over the age of 65
will then not be privileged in the same
way as people who are 20 and black
it makes no sense okay equity cuts
against justice
very often in the way that democrats
define equity because what they really
mean
is group outcomes being the same and it
doesn't matter what they have to do to
achieve that
that is dangerous dangerous stuff okay
as we'll see in just a second
the this is just part of the running
theme of the biden administration
or as biden himself might call it since
he is now governing exclusively by
executive fiat the biden dictatorship
okay so here is susan rice continuing
along these lines
susan wright says federal agencies will
be directed to take any steps to combat
xenophobia
okay here's the problem all of these
terms sound
like people are going to be empowered to
fight the bad things
the question is what are the bad things
we can probably agree on some of the bad
things that ought to be fought by the
federal government
and then there are some things that we
probably cannot agree on so here is
susan rice
using giant catch-all semantically
overloaded terms
to explain what the federal government
is going to do under her auspices
the president will sign a memorandum
directing all federal agencies
to take steps to combat xenophobia and
acts of violence against
asian americans and pacific islanders
who have been targeted
by political leaders in our nation's
response
to covet 19. again these are
continuation of our initial steps
to advance racial justice and equity
through early executive action okay so
nobody wants asian americans treated
with violence because nobody in america
should be treated with violence this is
one of the hallmarks
of being an american and having your
individual rights protected also when
she says
been treated by our political leaders
with xenophobia what she means by that
is that donald trump said chinese virus
that's what she means by that and we can
all read between the lines there you
don't have to read very far between the
lines
to get there okay that was not
xenophobic when trump said that it was
the china virus because it originated in
china
okay the the the the basic
terminology of of place from which it
originated is not in fact xenophobia but
again the goal here for the biden
administration is not going to be
anything approaching the protection of
individual rights it is going to be in
many cases precisely the opposite but
that is not where the executive power is
going to stop are you excited so chuck
schumer
it's amazing so the founders truly
believed that legislatures were going to
protect their own prerogatives
and the legislatures were not going to
allow the executive branch to infringe
on what the executive bra on what the
legislative branch does the people would
be zealous
of their own powers what the founders
didn't contemplate
is the idea that the legislature would
actually delegate all of its powers to
the executive
and then they would just become
basically a bunch of charity cases who
are living off the tax paradigm
to occasionally pass giant budget
busting omnibus packages
and that's what original originally that
was not a possibility because congress
couldn't do any of that
it's also true that the the congress
people the senators particularly were a
lot more wedded to their state
it used to be that senators were
appointed by their state legislatures
they're answerable to their state
legislatures now
they're not right they're directly
elected by the people which is a
horrible constitutional amendment
what does that mean it means that if
you're a senator your chief goal in life
is to avoid responsibility the easiest
way to avoid responsibility
is just saying that the executive should
do it so here is chuck schumer
the senate majority leader saying that
joe biden
should just use executive powers to do
whatever he wants
in fact he should use executive power to
declare climate change and emergency
and then he will be able to he will be
able to access
a bunch of emergency powers at his
disposal
and now you'll recall that some of us
warned about this when president trump
declared
the situation on our national border an
emergency
a national emergency and started using
executive power in order to do things
about it
some of us weren't um you might want to
go to the legislature for that because
once you start declaring things national
emergencies you have now opened the door
to democrats doing exactly this because
once you say that it's a national
emergency
then presumably the the executive the
president of the united states can now
declare that he wants cap and trade
or that he wants to shut down fracking
or that he wants to do a bunch of things
that he actually doesn't have the power
to do
because now it's a national emergency
here is the senate majority leader again
the leader of the majority in the senate
saying
the legislature should be completely
left behind biden should just go ahead
and do what he wants and declare climate
change a national emergency by the way
climate change is not a national
emergency it is not close to a national
emergency
climate change is not even a global
emergency climate change
is a thing that is happening it is going
to have some deleterious
effect over the course of the next
century and people are going to adapt as
they always have throughout human
history to a changing climate over time
the notion that if we do nothing right
now that tomorrow
tsunamis are going to wipe out half a
minute like that is not what an
emergency means
the eventuality of bad things happen
like i'll give you an example
the national debt is not a national
emergency that is something that
eventually is going to have to be paid
off
is going to result in massive austerity
programs cuts to government spending and
or increases in taxes and inflation
is that a quote-unquote national
emergency where the president can just
declare it no
bad things happening eventually over the
course of time is not a national
emergency but the goal here again the
point here
is that the executive in our country has
essentially become an elected
dictatorship that we can shift every
four years
joe biden used to acknowledge this until
he got the powers now he's real happy
with it here's chuck schumer
basically declaring himself irrelevant
and saying that joe biden should do
whatever he wants
i think it might be a good idea for
president biden to call a climate
emergency
why because then he can it relates to
what you're saying
then he can do many many things under
the emergency powers
of the president that wouldn't have to
go through that he could do without
legislation
now trump used this emergency for a
stupid wall which wasn't an emergency
but if there ever was an emergency
climate is one so i would
suggest that they explore
looking at climate as an emergency which
would give them more flexibility after
all it's a crisis
okay that's unbelievable the notion that
climate change which is a gradual change
in the climate over the course of
literally a century
is more of an emergency than vast
numbers of people
crossing our southern border illegally
in the now i didn't even think that was
a national emergency that should be
declared a national emergency that was a
problem it was not a national emergency
a national emergency is like we were
attacked right 911 national emergency
pearl harbor national emergency
climate change national emerald but
again the goal here is so that joe biden
can then use
powers delegated specifically for
emergencies in order to simply override
his actual executive powers
so for example you could use the
national emergencies act you can tap
into a suite of more than 100 additional
powers according to grist.com
those usually it's used in order to
enter for a natural disaster or
something
but there are some that are
theoretically kind of large so for
example
you could just redirect a bunch of money
from the pentagon toward building solar
panels
ooh or you can impose sanctions against
countries that use fossil fuels
or you could reinstitute a ban on u.s
exports of crude oil
you could send emergency aid packages to
states tribes and local governments
just simply on the basis of climate
change
okay so this is i'm sorry this is
ridiculous but but the goal here
is that joe biden should just govern
from the top he's just governed from the
top and by the way one of the ways he is
governing from the top
he has now announced that he's going to
pause oil and gas sales on public lands
according to the associated press he is
set to announce a wide-ranging
moratorium on new oil and gas leasing on
u.s lands and waters
as his administration moves quickly to
reverse trump administration policies on
energy
and the environment and address climate
change the drilling moratorium is among
several climate-related actions biden is
outlining on wednesday
according to two people with knowledge
of his plans who spoke on condition of
anonymity
biden is also likely to direct officials
to conserve 30 percent of the country's
lands
and ocean waters in the next 10 years
initiate a series of regulatory actions
to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions and elevate
climate change to a national security
priority uh again
how the executive ended up with this
much power it's frankly on the
legislature which has completely
abdicated its duty
my remember captain i'm not going to ban
fracking he's only going to be
unfracking where he can is the basic
idea here
and you know he's just going to get rid
of keystone xl and um
by the way we're not even doing the
fracking and we're not even doing the
drilling on keystone xl it's happening
in canada it's just a pipeline
but trying to move against fracking on
public lands is of course a way for him
to
number one undermine this isn't even
connected to climate change okay
fracking
is one of the single greatest reducers
of carbon emissions in the united states
because fracking has largely replaced
coal emissions as well as
normal oil exploration fracking
and natural gas significantly less
carbon emissions than those other forms
of power
all this is designed to do is cater to
his environmental left
good times also by the way he uh has his
plan to pause all deportations
so the acting secretary of department of
homeland security
david pakoski last wednesday wrote a
memorandum directing a dhs component
to conduct a review of policies and
practices concerning immigration
enforcement it sets interim policies
during the course of that review
including a 100 day pause on certain
removals to enable focusing the
department's resources
where they are most needed the uh that
that attempt to
place a moratorium on deportations has
now been held up by a texas judge
uh we'll see whether that eventually
holds up in court
so the powers that are being centralized
in the executive branch are exorbitant
they're going to be highly damaging just
be aware that this
is our form of government now it is not
a good form of government it is not a
constitutional form of government
and conservatives need to find every
legal auspices they can in order to
fight back that means using the courts
it means that congress needs to fight
back and grab back its own prerogatives
but unlikely to happen given the fact
that we are now an executive agency with
a vestigial legislature okay in just a
second
we're going to get to kovit policy
because the the supposed remember when
biden was campaigning on how he was
going to get control this thing get his
arms around it
in the first week he's just a mess he's
just a mess and by the way if you were
if trump had been as much of a mess
about coveted policy in the last week of
his administration
as biden were about covered policy in
the first week of his administration do
you think the coverage would be this
glowing
it's all glowing coverage for biden of
course yeah we'll get to that in just
one second first
let's talk about the fact you don't want
to go to an auto parts store you just
don't there's not a great reason to go
right now there's really not a great
reason to go ever you're going to go
there you're going to wait in the line
you're going to get to the front of the
line they're not going to have the part
they're going to order it online then
they're going to up charge you how about
instead of that you just skip
the auto parts store entirely and you go
to rockauto.com it's a lot easier than
walking into the auto parts store
answering a bunch of questions you don't
know the answer to
and then having them order the part
online anyway instead you just go to
rockauto.com and use the power of the
interwebs
at your desk in your pocket rockauto.com
will always offer the lowest prices
possible rather than changing prices
based on what the market will bear like
airlines do why would you spend up to
twice as much
for the same parts rockauto.com is a
family business that serves auto parts
customers online for 20 years
go to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
spend up to twice as much
for the same parts the rockauto.com
catalog is unique remarkably easy to
navigate
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle and choose the brands
specifications and prices
you prefer they've got amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car
will ever need rockauto.com head on over
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
right shapiro
in there how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you
already coming up we're going to do
covet policy which again it's just a
mess
get to that in a second first let me
remind you daily wire we are joining the
culture fights we have talked about the
culture war for long enough
we are now joining the culture war by
making our own content earlier this
month we released our first film run
hide fight exclusively for daily wire
members you can catch it over at
dailywire.com
on our mobile app or on our streaming
apps at apple tv and roku if you're not
a daily wire member yet
use promo code rhf to get 25 off that is
rhf for 25 percent off you'll notice if
you go to rotten tomatoes right now
that critics didn't like the film but
you loved it if you look at the viewers
they loved the film and that's the kind
of stuff we are going to be making stuff
that probably pisses off the critics
because critics are looking for wokeness
we are not going to be providing it so
if they are looking for wokeness they've
come to the wrong place
good news audiences tired of that stuff
as well and want an alternative
catch run hide fight over at
dailywire.com on our mobile app or on
our streaming apps at apple tv and roku
if you're not a daily wire member yet
use promo code rhf to get 25 off that is
rhf for 25
off you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
now the wonderful thing about
executive-run government is that our
executives are great at everything
if we know one thing it is that when you
centralize power in one
area of the government usually they're
amazing at it and if they fail it's
because they don't have enough power see
this is always the logic of the media
the president has enormous power in our
system if he is given
not enough power however then things
fail so we have to give him more power
but then if he fails that's because he
didn't have enough power
it's a completely unfalsifiable
proposition so joe biden has been
complaining
for a little under a year about how the
executive branch really needs to take
more control of the coveted response
because we need
more more power at the executive level
okay what if they suck at it what if
they're just bad at it
this never occurs to anybody it's
amazing as a country
we're essentially a bunch of morons i
mean gotta say
we complained constantly about the
government sucking at everything they
were like yes but if they had more power
perhaps that would fix the problem
okay that is the dumbest thing i've ever
heard
that's like me saying my kids make a
bunch of bad decisions every night like
they want to eat candy
all night and then run around in the new
this is what my my small small children
do
probably if i give them more power it'll
be better and the problem is i'm not
giving them enough control like
what are you talking about our
government just wants to go on sugar
benches and run around in the nude and
then it was like what if we just give
them more power
stop being idiots how about this if you
didn't i have an idea i know this crazy
idea here
okay let's say you're on the left and
you really hated trump you really hated
him you didn't like him he thought he
was bad
and you thought that he was a dictator
and really scary and now let's say
you're on the right and you look at
president biden and you say i don't like
that guy
that guy has way too much power and he's
exercising it in the wrong ways
i have an idea it's a crazy idea
okay it's an idea that's only been
considered by like you know the
constitution that idea is
the president has very little power how
about that if we go back to a system
where elected representatives who are
elected more than once every four years
and there's pretty high level of churn
and they are checked and balanced by
other forms of government
they leave you alone i know crazy right
and then you wouldn't care so much who's
the president of the
uh we're not gonna okay fine so we're
not gonna do that fine all right so here
is how coveted policy looks when it is
centralized
so within the last week joe biden has
now reversed himself 1273 times
don't worry he's the greatest
truth-teller who ever lived and also
captain normalcy who loves chocolate
chip ice cream
but he has reversed himself one million
seven hundred thirty two thousand times
in the last week on covet policy so for
example yesterday
literally yesterday joe biden the most
honest
and wondrous of all coveted leaders he
said that americans should all be able
to get the vaccine this spring if they
need it
when do you think anyone who wants one
would be able to get it
oh i know i i think it'll be this spring
i think we'll be able to do that this
spring
and uh but it's going to be a logistical
uh
challenge that exceeds anything we've
ever tried in this country but i think
we can do that
i feel confident that by summer we're
going to be well on our way
to heading toward herd immunity and
increasing the access for people who
aren't on the first on the list all the
way going down to
uh children so the spring right i mean
that's pretty exciting stuff that's
optimistic
stuff and also i don't know he's talking
about vaccinating like three year olds
that's not really something that we
should be considering
at this point um but um it turns out
that that wasn't true
whoops so here was joe biden today
he's now flipped it turns out not
everybody will be able to be vaccinated
in the spring now it'll be by the end of
summer
so at this rate within give him another
week and it'll be like the end of 2025
right because apparently every single
day he's adding a quarter onto his
estimate
here he was talking by the end of summer
probably maybe
we expect these additional 200 million
doses to be delivered
this summer and some of it will come as
early began to come in
early summer but by the mid by the
mid-summer
that this vaccine will be there and the
order
and and and that increases the total
vaccine order
in the united states by 50 from 400
million
order to 600 million this enough vaccine
to fully vaccinate 300 americans oh
by end of the summer the beginning of
the fall
wow that's a lot of vaccine for 300
americans i'll be honest with you i
thought that he was going to say 300
million americans right there
but for three i feel like that is enough
vaccine i feel like 600 million
is enough for 300 americans and then he
sort of fell asleep and that was
and that was sad okay so jen sackey the
white house
press secretary again her job is to fib
on behalf of
joe biden here she was walking back
biden literally over the past four days
so we have had
there was no vaccine plan that's a lie
we have had
we're going to vaccinate everybody by
the end of spring that was not true
we've gotten it's a massive increase in
dosage for us to
try to shoot for 100 million
vaccinations in a hundred days
that was not true we got we're gonna
vaccinate a hundred million americans in
a hundred days
that was not true because it turns out
that it's just gonna be a hundred
million first doses not
100 million second doses as well so
we've had all of that in the course of
the last week
here is jen said but don't worry it's
the most honest trustworthy
transparent and serious administration
you've ever seen it's amazing
here is jen sackey who literally gets
paid to just spin away all of joe
biden's problem so good luck to her
because that nude is barely sentient
what the president's goal is is ensuring
to that there's greater availability in
the spring
he will push his team he pushes his team
on covid and updates on it even when
it's a meeting about
other issues this is his focus every
single day um
and but the fact is every american is
not going to be eligible this spring
uh we're going to continue to increase
supply that's part of it um
and he has said many many times it's
going to take months and months
for a broad swath of the population to
be vaccinated oh goody
oh well that's that's exciting stuff by
the way i love when she's like he's
pushing his team he's pushing his team
dude couldn't push over one of those
inflatable
punching bags you know the ones that you
get for your kids where they punch them
and they kind of fall over joe biden
couldn't push that over like
he's pushing his team okay by the way
team biden is also lying about what is
happening
here in the states that i occupy florida
so on tuesday
joe biden's press secretary john sackey
who again says things that are untrue on
a fairly regular basis
suggested that florida was lagging
behind in vaccine distribution
saki should have noted that florida is
holding a lot of vaccines to give second
doses to elderly residents who have
already received the first dose
desantis has put out a statement he said
the insinuation that florida is under
utilizing vaccines is totally
disingenuous
florida is number one in the country
among the top 10 most populous states
for vaccine doses per capita
additionally florida is averaging more
than 300 000 first
doses per week but we are not going to
divert second doses away from our
seniors if the implication is that we
should be giving those second doses away
to other people
that is not the way the fda has
prescribed the series we are also number
one in the nation by far in vaccination
of seniors florida has vaccinated more
than one million seniors 65 and older to
date
if we're given additional first doses
we're ready to double our output
okay that was the response after gen
saki on monday suggested that desantis
was blowing it in florida again desantis
has become sort of the whipping post for
the democrats
which is insane because again florida
currently ranks
26th in the nation in deaths per million
despite having a population the same as
new york and significantly older meaning
significantly more vulnerable to covid
saki on monday had suggested that
they've only distributed 50
of the vaccines that they've been given
in florida so they have a lot of vaccine
okay literally the federal government
has told them they are not supposed to
distribute the second shots of vaccine
there's some people like me who say you
know what we shouldn't be holding those
into bans
we should literally just be giving out
everything that is there but as long as
the federal government is dictating that
you cannot do that
or you should not do that they don't get
to complain about that okay speaking of
which the greatest of all federal
responses being led by the greatest of
all possible doctors dr anthony fauci
now again i will note once more i have
not been anti-fauci this whole time now
i just find the guy to be unbelievably
annoying
and self-serving i think that he has
puffed himself up beyond all
accomplishment during this pandemic i
think he has accomplished very little
during this pandemic i think many of the
things that he has stated along the way
are untrue i think he's taken every
possible position that it is possible to
take
he has been both pro-masking and
anti-masking he has been both pro-hurt
immunity and anti-hurt immunity he has
been both
pro-opening the schools and pro-closing
the schools okay so here was anthony
fauci saying we need to rejoin the world
health
organization because the pandemic came
from china which makes no sense
literally the world health organization
acted as a pr agency for the chinese
while they lied to the rest of the
planet here's fauci saying we should
rejoin them anyway
certainly the who needs to have some
reforms there's no doubt about oh but
when you're dealing with a global
pandemic
you need a global organization to
coordinate
that means then that the door is open
that this could have come from a market
in wuhan
am i right about that what oh absolutely
i mean
that was one of the things that i've
been talking and my colleagues have been
talking about
for some time oh well well then
whoops also anthony fauci remember that
time that he said you shouldn't wear a
mask because
he was lying and then he said you should
definitely wear a mask because masks are
super important
now he's literally doubling down we
should wear two masks
according to anthony fauci it's amazing
two masks will do it guys
here's anthony fauci explaining two
masks will be great
this is a physical covering to prevent
uh droplets and virus to get in
so if you have a physical covering with
one layer you put another layer on it
just makes common sense
that it likely would be more effective
and that's the reason why you see people
either double masking or doing a version
of an n95
okay how about like three masks there
are some people who are recommending
that in fact today matt walsh
is going to be talking about all that
you can check out matt walsh's show at 1
30 p.m eastern
over at dailywire.com so there's a
graphic that msnbc put up
about this right and the graphic showed
the efficacy rate
for two masks and it was 75 and then the
efficacy rate for three masks which was
90 as one of our producers noted um
it would be fun if they showed the
efficacy rate for one mask which
actually is not all that high especially
if it is a cloth mask because that might
give the lie to the idea that masks are
going to be
the sole solution to this entire problem
but i i have
a better better solution i mean honestly
as long as we are just saying that you
should just be
strapping on the masks like i don't
understand my four isn't better
90 percent isn't good enough you want to
get to 100 we need at least four masks
i i feel like it's like xeno's paradox
like the more masks you wear
the smaller the increments of
improvement but if we're ever going to
get to 100
protection here what we're actually
going to need is what i call the plastic
bag solution this is where you take a
plastic bag you put it over your head
and then you take a rubber band and you
strap it around your neck now there are
some side effects you're not going to
dive covered if you do that
100 you're not going to die of covet
there are some bad
there's some side effects i'll admit
your oxygen intake will be
i mean you'll die but but you won't die
of covid and that's really really
the important thing i i don't know about
you but
i find it comforting to know that if i
just strangle myself then presumably i
will never die of covet
i'd like to remind you that if you're
under the age of 65 the rates of death
on coven
are under five and one thousand like
well under it
so yeah this seems this seems sensical
i'm sure that most americans are gonna
strap on 83 masks
this is all let's give these people more
power they're great at this
they're great at this speaking of which
when it comes to coveted policy
as we noted yesterday on this program
the teachers unions are in control and
these are the greatest and wisest people
these are the people who teach our
children which god help our kids
my seriously like god help them so the
chicago's teachers union has suggested
that they are not going to go back to
work
in fact they are currently engaged in
what most legal interpreters believe is
an illegal strike
backed by the american federation of
teachers backed by
the the biden administration presumably
the chicago teachers union has said
we are we are not going to reopen until
it's perfectly safe
what does that mean they've yet to say
they believe that
they need more diversity hires and i
have no idea why that has to do with
covert they they also are saying
that they want to make sure not just
that kids are wearing masks but that
every kid is is tested and is negative
or every kid is vaccinated like okay
it's just an excuse they don't want to
go back to work
and so they have i think provided us
with the greatest example of why
teachers unions should not exist i've
ever seen and i don't even mean the
strike
i mean that over the past 24 hours the
chicago teachers union
put out a little film of teachers unions
dance teachers dancing for school
closings i've never seen a better case
for defunding
the chicago teachers than this number
one that these people have jobs
and number two that these people feel
that this is important work what they
are doing right here so
here are six chicago teachers union dan
teachers
dancing for school closings it's
magnificent stuff
and uh i will i will give you what it
says underneath
safety is essential
keep our students and our teachers
safe
[Music]
our children deserve to be
um i don't think any of those people
should ever work again
i'm not a member of the council culture
but if i if i were if i were
everyone in this video should be
canceled
[Laughter]
yes yes you clearly are leading a very
difficult life being paid
to do nothing while dancing on a bridge
alone
good stuff
okay just this guy is just a bleep show
he literally
i can't believe this guy like there are
no words to describe how
horrible andrew cuomo is the guy won an
emmy they considered him
as a possibility for vp here is andrew
cuomo saying yesterday
that what we need is better government
more power better government
he said incompetent government kills
people does he own a mirror are mirrors
illegal in new york
new york has still still the second
worst deaths per million ratio
in america after new jersey here is
andrew cuomo
saying incompetent government kills
people i i just
th the lack of self-awareness it's
pretty incredible here he is give that
man an emmy
we were ambushed like no other state
nicole
and again it was from federal
incompetence
they thought the virus was in china it
had love china had gone to europe and it
came here for three months
before they ever knew incompetent
government
kills people incompetent government
kills people more people died than
needed to die
in covet that's the truth okay you know
what would be really bad
is if then somebody wrote a triumphal
book about their own leadership
on covid and then new york got hit by a
second wave of covet that'd be really
bad right that'd be kind of incompetent
leadership andrew cuomo i love nicole
wallace just in there
so true so true speaking of which
i just have to know the media continue
to just mirror all this crap
there's all there's all they exist to do
they're just state media that's what
they want to be that's what they want to
be
the washington post this week altered a
profile
of of kamala harris
okay so the it's pretty it's pretty
amazing so
there was a washington post story on
maya harris who's the sister of
kamala harris right who is then running
for president this is a story
back from july 2019 by ben terrace okay
the lead of the story
was this incredibly awkward and weird
story in which kamala harris
was talking about how campaign was like
a prisoner a campaign made her feel like
a prisoner
kamala harris described to her sister in
this story how preparations for a
democratic primary debate in miami
had allowed her to break from the
grueling primary campaign schedule quote
it's a treat that a prisoner gets when
they ask for a morsel of food please
kamala said shoving her hands forward as
if clutching a metal plate her voice
now trembling like an old british man
locked in a dickensian jail cell
and water i just want your standards
really go out the effing window
okay so that was in the original profile
of kamala harris back in july 2019.
kind of a telling thing right that she
is treating herself as a victim
as though she's living in a prison right
now what did the washington post do
well they were putting together a
compendium of pieces on kamala harris
because she's the new vice president
they cut it they just disappeared it
eric baum of reason magazine pointed out
that the post deleted
that passage from the maya harris
profile instead they replaced it with a
more conventional introduction
in a new version published this month
finding people to trust in politics a
field full of mercenaries with their own
interests at heart can be a tough thing
to do uh isn't that nice
so why exactly would they just get rid
of that paragraph
the post says it repurposed and updated
stories about harrison biden for its
inaugural coverage
oh is that what they did so you wouldn't
want people to have that awkward feeling
of
recognizing that kamal harris was a
terrible candidate and is in fact not a
wonderful human being they instead they
just cut
it they just cut it so that's exciting
stuff other exciting things are
happening as well
in the world of wonderful media so for
example
the la times the la times is now going
to introduce
a beat it is called covering up kamala
harris
here is how they described it in a tweet
quote
kamala harris is the first vice
president who is black south asian
female and the direct descendants of
immigrants well i mean that's pretty
specific
i wouldn't expect there to be that many
vice presidents who are who are
all of the above black south asian
female and the direct descendants of
immigrants i mean that's that's a lot
right there
well done introducing covering kamala
harris a beat dedicated to her historic
rise
to the white house follow us on
instagram
and then there's a picture of kamala
harris
looking out at the camera wistfully
it's kind of an animation it's like this
actually weird kind of creepy animation
and then the background is this rainbow
of color wow
the la times honestly why bother having
an
office of an office of press relations
when you just have the l.a times for you
meanwhile daniel dale captain fact check
over there
so he uh he wrote a piece yesterday
called fact-checking seven statistical
claims from biden's quite factual
economic speech oh you mean the fact
checkers are just gonna go right to
sleep over at cnn that's exciting stuff
they're only gonna fact check
the stuff that's accurate they're just
going to skip the part that's inaccurate
so we're probably not going to do tons
of fact checking
on all of his vaccine failures thus far
like all of his untruths thus far we're
not going to fact-check that sort of
stuff
are we meanwhile over at newsweek so tom
cotton
there's a piece at newsweek claiming
that tom cotton had engaged in stolen
valor
because he served in the 101st airborne
so i mean that's the thing
he also graduated from army ranger
school he called himself an army ranger
okay well there they say you're not
allowed to call yourself an army ranger
unless you actually serve
with the rangers right because he didn't
he served in the 101st
battalion which is bad he's not now it's
stolen valor
okay so there's only one problem
newsweek wrote a piece in 2015
in which they talked about two women
becoming rangers after graduating from
the army
ranger school okay so what did newsweek
do they had this
they had this conflict right because
they had one piece saying that tom
cotton had stolen valor by calling
himself an army ranger
after graduating from ranger school then
they had another piece from 2015 where
they themselves
acknowledged that people who graduated
from ranger school were in fact
known as rangers so what did they do
according to national review cotton's
office contacted newsweek this weekend
to point out that newsweek had
identified female ranger school
graduates as army rangers in 2015.
newsweek responded by editing its 2015
story to confirm
to conform to salon's new smear of
cotton the 2015 newsweek story no longer
says the two women will quote become
rangers
the edited version says they will quote
be allowed to wear the coveted ranger
tab
on their uniforms so they're going back
in now
and re-editing old stories not just the
washington post newsweek two they're
re-editing old stories
and they are just rewriting history i
mean this is like when people say
orwellian this is actually like straight
from orwell where the guy
who's the main character in 1984
literally sits there and rewrites
historical stories to conform to modern
day
ideas so they are now going and
rewriting old stories to conform to the
narrative that tom cotton has engaged in
stolen valor
and the narrative that kamala harris is
a wonderful person who never says
awkward things
they're just doing this in real time
that shouldn't really be a shock i mean
the dictionary did this with the term
preference after mazie hirono idiot
senator
decided that it was a wonderful
wonderful idea to suggest that amy coney
barrett
was somehow a homophobe for using the
term sexual preference
yeah the media are the the the extent to
which the media are just going to be a
government outlet
at this point it's pretty hard to it's
pretty hard to overstate that
great example so yesterday peter ducey
uh was
was talking to joe biden right he was
questioning joe biden
and ducey asked a pretty solid question
which is biden had had
a phone call with vladimir putin and
ducey said so what did you talk about
putin right no
perfectly normal question and biden
immediately responds
by by kind of ripping on ducey because
this is the way it's going to be
in the white house press room
essentially there's going to be the one
reporter
who is the gadfly who all the rest of
the press hate because he's killing the
vibe
the vibe in that room is supposed to be
the vibe on a porn on a porn shoot
and here is peter zucci over there
ringing a cowbell and saying you know
guys
when you want to leave off the looping
you might at some point want to ask a
difficult question
and joe biden's gonna be like that guy
see that guy he's ah that guy and
everybody laughs
that's exactly what happened at the
press conference yesterday
you so if you can't hear it peter ducey
says so what did you talk to putin about
and he says you he sends his best yeah
imagine if donald trump had said that
you think the media would have would
have covered that a little differently
donald trump refuses to answer questions
about vladimir putin and their
discussion
yes our intrepid media not just there
to uh cover joe biden but to physically
wipe his ass
exciting exciting stuff okay meanwhile
here is your impeachment update here's
your impeachment update so
yesterday rand paul sponsored a bill uh
it was designed to go essentially a
resolution
that suggested that impeachment was
illegal because
donald trump is no longer impeachable
because he's no longer president of the
united states now
i think the legal case on that is
somewhat sketchy i think there's a
fairly solid constitutional argument
that you can in fact be convicted by the
senate after you are
impeached after you are in office in
order to borrow you from running again
nonetheless 45 republican senators voted
against the impeachment which means
nobody's gonna vote in favor of the
impeachment right it's gonna be it's
gonna be the five that we already know
about who are likely to vote
in favor of the impeachment that would
probably be mitt romney
it's going to be murkowski it'll be
susan collins it'll be
ben sasse right that will be the crew
essentially
everybody else is not i mean even mitch
mcconnell who is sort of suggesting that
he might vote in favor of impeachment it
seems like he is moving
pretty hard against that tattooing of
pennsylvania is the other one
rand paul tweeted out the senate just
voted on my constitutional points of
order
45 senators agreed the sham of a trial
is unconstitutional
that is more than will be needed to
acquit until eventually end this
partisan impeachment process the trial
is dead on arrival in the senate now
the the statements that are put out by a
variety of republicans are worth
talking about so tim scott senator from
south carolina was quite critical of
trump
he he put out a statement he said i'm
unconvinced the senate has the authority
to hold a trial against a private
citizen
if president trump was such an
existential threat why did speaker
pelosi rush the impeachment only to wait
12 days to send the article to the
senate
if the purpose of this trial is to
remove a president that was already done
on january 20th when trump left the
white house
but now once again the senate is faced
with the time-consuming task of
determining the merits of yet another
article of impeachment on now former
president trump
we need to get back to the people's work
we need to get vaccines distributed save
small businesses
etc and by the way i think that that
last statement is going to reflect
american opinion quite fast here if this
continues to drag on and people still
can't get the vaccines and the economy
continues to be in the doldrums people
are gonna be like why are you spending
time on this again
trump is not the president anymore
okay but here is the the broader
argument against impeachment the broader
argument against impeachment is once
again
there is no objective standard by which
trump's conduct
is quote unquote impeachable the reason
i say the reason i say quote unquote
there is because you can impeach for
literally anything
impeachment is a political process it is
not in fact a legal process but
the question is what standard are you
using to impeach trump if the standard
being used to impeach trump is that
trump engaged in prevarication about the
outcome of an election
can be real hard to do that and set a
neutral standard given the fact that for
four years democrats kept claiming over
and over and over that donald trump was
not in fact the rightful president of
the united states and that he had worked
with the russians in order to gain the
system
if the standard is that donald trump
used inflammatory language
in order to incite violence then you run
into another problem which is you're
either going to have to
impeach pretty much everybody who
engaged in inflammatory language
or you don't have a neutral standard if
the standard is that donald trump
challenged an election that was legally
held and legally certified and that
anybody who challenges an election that
is legally held and legally certified
needs to be thrown out of congress well
then you end up at the maisy hirono
position the dumbest person in the
united states senate hears the senator
from hawaii saying
that it's not just that trump should be
impeached it's that ted cruz and josh
halley
should be thrown out of the senate
these two senators they they did more
than just simply have a disagreement
uh over the election results they were
very busy
just putting off the lie that that this
election was stolen so they were
ringleaders and we're not for these two
senators basically
needing the charge in the senate to sign
on to these these objections
even though a hundred house republicans
objected those objections would have
gotten nowhere so
they needed senators to sign on to the
objections and
senators holly and cruz provided that
leadership on the senate side
to contest a fair and free election
result okay so the goal for a lot of
democrats again is not just to lump in
trump with the rioters but also to lump
in cruz and halle
with the rioters and then to lump and
presumably everybody who
wanted to challenge election results
even though i think that is wrong they
want to lump them in with the actual
people who did physical violence
and then they want to lump in every
conservative with those people right
that is the that is the eventual goal
here and they're being fairly clear
about this
and again there is no actual hard
standard by which this constituted legal
incitement
there's a point that rand paul made
again i'm less enthused by the
by the constitutional idea that you
can't impeach somebody who's already out
of office i'm more
i'm more motivated by rand paul's
argument here
he says you know you guys are using a
pretty interesting standard of
incitement
considering that um you literally will
not say a damn word about people in your
own party using inflammatory language
and then people
using that inflammatory language as an
excuse to do violence but now you want
to imp trump over it here's rand paul
making this point
no democrat will honestly ask whether
bernie sanders incited the shooter
that nearly killed steve scalise and
volunteer coach
the shooter nearly pulled off a massacre
i was there
because he fervently believed the false
and inflammatory rhetoric
spewed by bernie and other democrats
such as the republican health care plan
for the uninsured
is that you die as this avowed bernie
supporter shot steve scalise nearly
killing him
and shot one of our coaches and two or
three of our staff he screamed
this is for health care ask me or anyone
if that's incitement
okay rand paul happens to be correct
about this and people who are vague in
their standards should not be surprised
when those standards come around to bite
them directly on the tulkas
if your standard for incitement is use
inflammatory language and politics
pretty much everybody is toast pretty
much but again the goal here
for democrats is really threefold one is
the moral castigation of every single
republican
right the only republicans who are good
republicans are the ones who do our work
in this moment
according to the left right mitt romney
is their friend right now wait until
mitt romney does something they don't
like
he'll become an enemy again very very
quickly okay so goal number one all
republicans are bad
regardless of what you think about the
election and
no matter whether you condemn the
capital riots you are bad
right not just that also this creates a
political conundrum for republicans if
republicans vote against
the impeachment then the idea is that
the republican party has backed trump
and trump will be the guy
going forward and if the republican
party does back impeachment and gets rid
of trump then trump is motivated to run
revenge campaigns against republicans so
that is what democrats are setting up
right here and when they're on their
moral high horse about like i'm not
going to listen to joy behar and her
moral high horse here
i i'm sorry she has no leg to stand on
she's like well anybody who'd voted not
to convict
they blood on their hands truly joy
behar
just going to point out i know that
we're not supposed to make this
comparison because it happens to be a
perfectly apples to apples comparison
but the entire democratic party
infrastructure essentially
backed the case behind black lives
matter said that it was wonderful
worth pursuing black lives matter ended
with two billion dollars
in damages across the united states and
at least a dozen
deaths on its hand i don't hear any of
these people who are using
extraordinarily inflammatory language
talking about the blood on their own
hands of course they're never going to
talk about that
because frankly they don't you only have
blood on your hands if you direct people
to do violence
nonetheless this is the talking point
for democrats and joy behar being the it
of the democratic party just spills it
right out
these people who are not going to vote
for a conviction will be remembered
we will remember them because if they
let him go without
any kind of accountability trump
this will happen again it will happen
again and we will remember those names
of that senate senators and the house
people
who decided not to convict this guy
because the blood is on their hands then
okay i'm sure that all those republican
senators are gravely fearful
of the wrath of joy behar because you
know if they if they had voted to
convict probably joy behar would
probably vote for them
or not there's a basic rule that now
applies in american politics if the only
people ripping you
is unfortunate because principle no
longer applies if the only people
ripping you
are the people on the other side you're
basically fine everybody knows that
right left and center because anybody
who thinks that
joy behar or chuck schumer or nancy
pelosi are repositories of principle on
this thing
yeah i i really really don't think so
all right we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content in
the meantime go check out matt walsh's
show
it is up at 1 30 p.m eastern i'm ben
shapiro this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavo wiedowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam scievents
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021
on the matt well show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics
but culture faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show